blog numero 10 oggi un piccolo permesso
speciale perché devo portare questi due
veterinari richiamo del vaccino quindi
mi è stato concesso di allontanarmi ecco
non solo dalla casa il tempo di fare il
vaccino e rientrare ancora fatto
mangiare quindi incazzati neri oggi sono
super contenta perché tocca a me
intortare guido a fare una passeggiata e
dato che ho visto che con bush funzione
tipo ti il momento di incontro con i
pensieri aiuto
ecco spuntare tutti quanti insieme e in
più lavorare in più lo stress
devo dire che non è la cosa più agevole
del mondo ma devo ammettere che sia
bellissima che mi ritengo molto
fortunata ad avere questa famiglia
realtà voglio ucciderla comunque quegli
anni passanti riflessioni [ __ ]
importanti quando porta a guido a spasso
a me non viene niente di intel in trent
da dire ma vai a capodanno
di norma seca volano
oddio sono immediati da tutti ei
[Musica]
dipendenti gli uccellini cenerentola noi
parlare così a 76
chi c'è ne vado seguimi
quando sono a casa non hai sentito il
mio poco o forse no ma è boom
mandiamolo
[Applauso]
[Risate]
libero per entrare in diretta ai
microfoni come funziona la notte non
aspettate un attimo senso del dovere che
si prega di troppo il sesso come queste
classi ma che stai facendo
loris 6 del miglior parma che aveva
visto il migliore dando un banner co2
scambi dopo torino se preferisci
è il senso del dovere da gabriele
occupato di casa un cazzo mia madre che
ha mandato un dono questo punto
all'inizio nel piatto e della ma dal
grande carriera che la situazione era
borri possiamo mettere queste citazioni
che non fanno ridere al messi lì a
citofono
sì sette giorni possiamo fare un attimo
un comunicato alle persone stanno
seguendo questo blog ma soltanto di
chiedo scusa per il pp non penso che una
canzone è spaccata io lo sapevo che
succedeva attacco la sua unica maglietta
la mia unica maglietta e lamine vorremmo
fare un piccolo appello a tutti quanti
voi come capite il nostro tipo di
intrattenimento e leggermente più alto
rispetto al delirio che sta avvenendo
creato perché che abbia contagiato ormai
tutti anche valentina contemporanea da
una parte non riesco a capire a volte la
vedo che in qualche modo cede al lato
oscuro quindi vi chiedo scusa perché
questo qui più che un blog ma sembra uno
zoo
secondo me valentina non cede ne è
affascinata anni e ghermita quindi
aspetta i commenti sotto poi stanno
scippando gabriele valentini una volta
con i cerchietti tranquillo tranquillo
note parlare dove la gente tifa
scippando gogh apre con l'amichevole
delle tic e quindi ragazzi potete
scrivere qua sotto hashtag free the
three o ti prego liberateci
di odio e di rancore da questo guarda io
ti odio
io l'ho capito benissimo regale ho visto
a napol dire famiglia scusa ma non
esistono mestoli in questa casa
vuoi vedere una cosa ecco qua è stato un
genitore madre la mette giustamente di
questa rete
se vi piace come faccio con la porzione
che mangerò io adotterò questa tecnica
anche su di momento io vorrei una
liquidate di con un po d'acqua
no no non ci mette l'acqua e ci ho messo
a milano nella programmazione ci mettono
alla prova la mente lucida
siamo contenti siamo contenti siamo
contenti
manga
che posso di una cosa colla kabanga
qualsiasi cosa cambia favore possa
essere per te una luce durante
l'oscurità anche dentro la tradisce lo
staff introdotte la luce di aqaba
[Applauso]
[Musica]
notevole dire chi non ci sono stato se
non per portare all'inizio di questo
blog dei gatti apparsi delle punture ci
sono quindi mi stai dicendo che un'altra
presenza finanza neanche quando sente
come un buco del culo sgomito era un
classico sapeva voi domani e dopodomani
no non lavori domani non sei neanche
quando lavori per cappello quel cassano
anche qui di fianco alla fine è sì che
chi viene da girando il cappello non
sono il capo dei tuoi clienti sono il
tuo capo ti ho detto che devi togliere
quel cazzo di carmelo bene anche tu te
ti rispondo solo io ma ho già lavorato
ieri questo momento sto tenendo le mani
non essere più tranquillo di questa
caccia
davvero spero che arrivino le forze
armate a portarci fuori di qui io sono
disposto a mettere uno per il resto del
blog mas in carcere è pronto ora modo di
chiamare il marcio è perfetta ma tutta
entra guglielmo uniti che l'alto diranno
niente cosa che costa della cittadina
questa è follia pura pazzia totale a
fine anno quindi dopo li porteremo qui è
dove combatteremo qui è dove voli l'anno
ciao ragazzi ho bisogno di un consiglio
obiettivo nel senso si è divertente non
senza divertente la follia ormai sono
pure eppure giorni che qua non si
respira più un clima tranquillo sono
usciti con delle sedie un giro per roma
hanno scippato una ragazza io avrei
voluto tanto farebbe ma se nei quali si
respirava il clima del natale la
felicità ha capito sia prima un dialogo
e ne so sulla famiglia
invece questo gatto per sta cercando di
venire qui mangiarsi no le mie le in
coppie
mancano solo due settimane ce la posso
fare ce la posso fare
ragazzi quella di oggi è stata una
giornata intensa felice qui in questo
delirio da domani bisogna rimettere
ordine e quando non ci dovessimo vedere
domani pomeriggio
buonasera dei buonanotte